zombies snowmen giant snakes and the
worst cgi you've ever seen think you
loved these movies think again
washington irving's classic horror story
the legend of sleepy hollow has been
adapted to the screen numerous times one
of the most notable iterations is tim
burton's 1999 film sleepy hollow
starring the director's most frequent
collaborator johnny depp as ichabod
crane fans of burton who grew up
familiar with this revered gothic style
were eager to see him try his hand at an
r-rated horror film and he's certainly
delivered upon the movie's tagline heads
will roll
clean as dandelion heads apparently
despite triumph at the box office
generally positive reviews from critics
and three academy award nominations the
movie seemed to disappear into the fog
following its release sleepy hollow
remains a visually stunning achievement
and it certainly has its fans but it has
failed to garner any kind of enduring
fandom nowadays it has mostly been
forgotten
from the tornadoes of twister to the
eruptions of dante's peak planetary
seemed to be under constant assault in
1990 cinema the disaster genre is rife
with unforgettable scenes of nature's
fury and destruction but mimi leather's
comet-based action thriller deep impact
sadly imploded before it could really
get going deep impact actually enjoyed
some early success at the start of the
summer of 98 but then a month later the
unthinkable happened armageddon although
critics were harsher on michael bay's
movie it's outshined deep impact in two
key ways it had more consistent action
set pieces with stronger production
value and it featured stronger more
memorable characters the only enduring
action and deep impact arrives late in
the final act when a comet strikes the
atlantic ocean and triggers an enormous
tidal wave this leads to the movie's
most famous sequence in which new york
city is swallowed by the terrifying
tsunami unfortunately everything before
the comet's arrival is a bit of a slug
deep impact features unnecessarily large
ensemble casts occupying fractured
storylines and none of them are really
compelling enough to stand on their own
the recipient of six razzie nominations
including worst couple for jon voight
and an animatronic snake anaconda is
something of a notorious legend in
hollywood history jennifer lopez icecube
and owen wilson star as members of a
film crew shooting a documentary about a
lost tribe in the amazon they cross
paths with a snake hunter who offers to
help them but instead takes some hostage
and hoodwinks them into helping him
track down a legendary enormous green
anaconda that lives deep in the jungle
dismal reviews from critics didn't
hinder the film's performance at the box
office likely fueled by word of mouth
regarding its status as a so bad as good
classic and it's a laugh at times a
comically large sometimes animatronic
sometimes cgi anaconda is vindictive to
the point of pettiness screeching like a
pterodactyl as it plucks off the crew
one by one while these scenes are
genuinely hilarious however the
remainder of the movie is a snooze voigt
is the only actor who seems to have
understood the assignment whereas the
rest of the cast plays the bonkers
script way too seriously there's a devil
inside everyone
everyone waited with baited breath to
see how alicia silverstone would follow
up her performance in clueless arguably
one of the best high school movies of
all time as such it was no surprise that
excess baggage caved under these
unreasonably high expectations although
the movie notoriously bombed the box
office and in critics estimations it
remained popular among silverstone
die-hards who were thrilled to see the
actor try her hand at a more dramatic
turn still not even that could prevent
this tonally uneven formulated crime
comedy from becoming a forgotten relic
of the 1990s
the christmas genre is chock full of
movies that viewers come back to year
after year unfortunately troy miller's
1998 family fantasy jack frost failed to
secure a spot in the pantheon of holiday
movies perhaps the movie's fatal flaw is
that jack frost begins with the grim
death of a semi-absent father setting a
fairly morbid somber tone from the start
not only suffocates the story as it
trudges on the father spirit returns in
the form of a live-speaking snowman and
tries to reconnect with his troubled son
things just keep getting creepier from
there as the movie spirals into a mess
of four sentimentalism and dated cgi
ravaged by critics and considered a box
office dud jackfrost is a movie many
teens enjoyed in the 1990s with their
families and then wisely consigned it to
the history books
runway hughes 1999 rom-com forces of
nature was poised for success even after
it was met with harsh reviews from
critics the movie follows writer ben
holmes as he treks back to his hometown
of savannah georgia for his wedding
ben's travel plans are appended when he
crosses paths with free-spirited offbeat
sarah on his flight before a seagull
flies into their plane's jet engine
grounding them when a brewing hurricane
leads all other flights to be cancelled
ben and sarah are forced to team up and
find an alternate path south leading to
a screwball journey that leaves ben
questioning his commitment to his
fiancee even when ben and sarah's
hijinks veer into the cartoonish forces
of nature was a pleasant watch in the
late 1990s mostly due to ben affleck and
sandra bullock's shia star power but the
movie is rarely discussed this side of
the 21st century likely due to a
forgettable plot and sarah's passe manic
pixie dream girl characterization this
is a film that was simply never destined
to leave the 90s
following in the colossal footsteps of
jurassic park and godzilla lake placid
took a stab at the monster genre and by
most accounts missed by a long shot
still the bizarre concept of an enormous
30-foot saltwater crocodile terrorizing
a lake in upstate new york managed to
drive curious audiences to the theaters
despite a wickedly hilarious supporting
performance delivered by the late great
betty white this creature features goofy
thrills wore off quickly it is virtually
impossible to recall anything that's
happened in the movie apart from the
infamous scene in which white leaves a
blindfolded cow to be consumed in a
single vicious chomp
this is due to a heavy reliance on flat
b-movie characterization aimless
plotting and the cheesy scripts that was
inexplicably written by david e kelly
one of the most celebrated writers in
television drive me crazy is a prime
example of how a movie can be forgotten
when another one does the same plot but
better named after the 1999 britney
spears song featured on its soundtrack
this melissa jonehart and adrian grenier
starring romantic comedy was released
eight months after she's all that a
movie that was much better and more
successful drive me crazy never escaped
his competitor's shadow hart was at the
height of her popularity right in the
middle of her run on sabrina the teenage
witch but this was grenier's mainstream
breakthrough having only starred in a
handful of small independent films
although drive me crazy fed worse with
critics she's all that was never exactly
bound for the criterion collection the
latter employs the same trite ugly
duckling gets a makeover conceders drive
me crazy but with better chemistry
between the leads which really makes or
breaks these kinds of movies she's all
that basically obliterated drive me
crazy from the 1990s teen rom-com cannon
and even went on to inspire a
genderflipped netflix remake in 2021
james foley's 1996 stalker drama fear
was a provocative must see among teens
at the time but today it's cringe
inducing dialogue and nonsensical plot
reeks of unintended camp characterized
by one of its producers as fatal
attraction for teens the psychological
thriller stars mark woolberg as
mysterious bad boy david and depicts the
toxic relationship he pursues with his
younger girlfriend nicole once nicole's
father digs into david's past and
discovers david is not the person he
claims to be he tries to persuade his
daughter to end things only stoking
david's troubling timber in fairness
wolberg delivers a truly chilling
performance as david develops his
unhealthy obsession with nicole and his
character's volatility was amusing to
watch as a teenager today though it is
difficult to enjoy fear even as a hate
watch mostly due to its glimped
portrayal of psychological and physical
abuse
saturday night live movie spin-offs do
not have the strongest track record
bruce mccullough's 1999 movie superstar
included molly shannon's catholic school
girl mary catherine gallagher remains
one of snl's most beloved recurring
characters short comedy sketches proved
to be the ideal forum for shannon to
play mary catherine giving her the space
to tap into the character's
unpredictable intensity of putting
social awkwardness and physical comedy i
guess that's a catholic thing
expanding shannon's character into a
full-length feature heroine movie proved
challenging however forcing superstar to
rely on long drawn out sight gags that
often suffocate the movie's pacing
teenagers in the 1990s often mimicked
mary catherine's sticks and catchphrases
but these are all prime examples of
things that are best left in the late
1990s along with the movie itself
after writing the screenplays for some
of the most popular teen slasher movies
from the 1990s kevin williamson was
riding a huge wave of acclaim and
expectation for his directorial debut
williamson returned to a screenplay he
had written prior to his rapid ascent to
fame teaching mrs tingle this black
comedy follows high school student lee
ann as she enlists her friends to hold
reviled teacher mrs tingle hostage after
she gave the annapol grade on a project
and threatened to dethrone her status as
class valedictorian
the dark premise piqued the interest of
every teenager who dreamt of seeking
revenge on a mean teacher from high
school but considering the rise in
school violence since its release
teaching mrs tingle now feels in poor
taste there was also an undeniable
novelty in seeing a revered actress like
helen mirren partaking something so low
brow
but saddled with a schlocky script and
ghastly reviews teaching mrs tingle was
always doomed to be a one-and-done
based on two stories by the science
fiction literary master isaac asimov
chris columbus's 1999 fantasy drama
bicentennial man stars the late robin
williams who truly disappears into his
role as andrew martin a robotic domestic
worker who yearns to become a human
being however what starts out with a
charming fish out of water story quickly
dissolves into modern existentialism as
andrew discovers the limits of his
ability to emulate human feelings the
movie struggles to understand what it
wants to communicate to its audience
employing increasingly emotionally
manipulative tactics to entertain
children and emotionally stir adults
critics were mostly mixed from the film
and the box office numbers were not
encouraging few actors have enjoyed as
much consistent success as williams in
the 1990s but bicentennial man is too
much of a bummer to deserve a second
viewing which is why when it comes to
william's best work it is perennially
absent from the conversation
inspired by the classic fairy tale
little red riding hood writer and
director matthew bright's freeway
featured a breakthrough performance from
rhys witherspoon one that kicked off her
long and successful career with the
spoon stars as vanessa a troubled
teenager and little red riding hood
surrogate who is left alone to fend for
herself after her mother is arrested she
evades a social worker trying to help
her and goes on the run to track down
her elusive grandmother unwittingly
hitching a ride with a wanted serial
killer the trip quickly descends into
chaos leading vanessa to commit heinous
acts of violence in order to survive
freeway was favored by critics and
audiences alike but never garnered the
level of fandom needed to catapult it
into cult movie territory the gritty
road comedy thriller felt edgy and
audacious when it debuted at the 1996
sundance film festival
firt feels antiquated by today's
standards and has since virtually
disappeared from public consciousness
[Music]